it was an early morning for common who
announced the nominations for the 23rd
annual screen actors guild awards
alongside sophia-bush Tuesday there's so
many like really talented people being
nominated it's just exciting the rapper
also spoke out about his pal Kanye and
his recent meeting with president-elect
Donald Trump what did you make of all
that I mean you know that's my good
brother Kanye so you know Kanye's is his
own man and it when the choices he makes
them you know I'm gonna support him
unless it's something that's detrimental
to him so like if that's what he chose
to do everything we don't necessarily
have to agree on but that's my brother
you must be proud because it says a lot
about a man who has the power to meet
with the future president about issues
you know that are important to well you
know we've we've had the opportunity to
meet with our president now like what's
been really strong because I'm he has a
program called my brother's keeper which
is beyond not only what he's done in the
White House but he will continue to do
if he gets out of the White House so
like and and our president embraced a
lot of people from all walks of life so
yeah we've had that opportunity and we
want to keep keep being active in and
out in our society
you